there was something that happened the
other day
you don't have to make that face because
you don't have to think about it as soon
as I say something you're going to know
exactly what I'm talking about
in Cleveland
oh yeah
there was a uh a bra that kind of went
on and to me
you know when you're playing a sport
trying to feed your family
you're around the boys all day every day
for eight months including spring
training
you know things just kind of boil or it
could be anything right somebody just
accidentally trip you and it could be
guys could be having a bad day you never
know
and so uh that happened and
that was kind of crazy I I would have
been the Umpire the Umpire he started in
there named Matt he started in there and
he backed out of there he was out of
there quick
you guys can have it that's what I would
have did you know but I did want to just
say like
you know things like that happen man and
it is TA is my boy ta me ta is really my
boy and
he got him you know what I'm saying he
just got got you know sometimes it is
what it is but
you know that I think it's just really
just things kind of just boiled over and
somebody's probably just having a bad
day and I know you don't have to we had
a team meeting about it oh you guys had
a team meeting yeah so I mean you don't
have to give me all the details about
the team meeting but like give me
something about the meeting players only
oh nice okay yeah tell me basically
we said that we said if if someone gets
knocked out on the field there is no way
that there is not a not nothing thrown
after that oh I mean no no one fought
after yeah that was kind of just yeah
they kind of stood around they did yeah
you got to protect your boy right you do
got to protect your boy and
you know if there's a fight that breaks
out with us
I love us I love you guys I love you
guys Adele
I don't I'm just gonna be pulling people
out of there don't expect me to come
throw elbows punch I'm just not made
like that all right so so that's that's
our agreement if we ever brawl we'll
come hold each other back
a truce